F: Salut en ce magnifique lundi avec ce magnifique temps à l'extérieur.
On est revenu en hiver.
Je vous présente le vlog de la semaine.
Il y a quelques jours j'ai été invité au théâtre du Trévisse
pour la première des coups de boost de l'humour là bas.
Et je vous ai emmené avec moi.
Et petite annonce :
le Vlog de la semaine prochaine sera sur la dernière de mon plateau
Hallucinations collectives et autres illusions fantastiques,
qui a lieu ce soir à 21h30.
Si vous êtes sur Paris ce soir à 21h30 on fait la dernière.
Il y aura Kamel le Magicien,
il y aura Zapata,
il y aura Philippe Roche,
y aura Djamel Kaibou, également Artus et puis bien sûr moi.
Sinon il n'y a pas trop de sens.
Et si vous venez faites le moi savoir à la fin j'aimerai bien faire 2-3 images avec vous pour le vlog.
Mais pour le moment je vous emmène dans les loges.
Gaëtan: Tu vlog ?
F: Je vlog.
G: Tu allumes ta caméra et tu dis
"Voilà durant les 2 prochaines heures c'est moi qui vais vous parlez".
F: C'est toi qui parle du coup.
G: D'accord, bon bien je vlog.
F: Et après je fais une morning routine.
G: Là tu m'as perdu.
Et du coup, ça m'a mit une baffe,
et j'ai dis "Mais je sais exactement ce que je veux faire :
aller vers la stupidité infinie."
F: Ça c'est Alex avec qui on a fait la vidéo ...
euh ... *claque des doigts*
A: Non.
F: Non.
*rire d'Alex*
F: Merci Alex.
A: Mais non c'est vrai. On a pas fait la vidéo.
F: Ben non tu ne me réponds pas à mes messages Facebook.
A: Mais arrête tes conneries. Tu veux que je te le montre devant la caméra.
F: Ouais
[du fond de la pièce] Ben dis donc vous êtes parti où les mecs? Je savais pas ça que...
F: Je vais te faire voir mec
A: Merci à plus
[Fond de pièce]: Il y a du coming out là
F: Non non non mon dernier message
elle, non non j'étais pas dispo et pareille demain on essaie de se recaler ça vite
et je met ça marche bise donnes moi tes dispos
Je met ça
A: Donnes moi tes dispos non il y a pas ça
*rires*
F: Ouais j'avoue
F: Si je filme que tu me filmes
J: Vas y vas y fait péter man
Fais y péter son maté... tu as vu un trou noir là aussi?
F: Ouais *rires*
*rires*
F: Est ce que quelqu'un veut réellement voir le trou noir de Jeanfi?
J: Ouais, beaucoup à Paris...
F: Je propose de mettre un sondage en fin de vidéo pour ça
J: Met un sondage
*rires*
F: Si je met cette image là et en quelques secondes
Alfred: Ouais
F: Il y aura 50 commentaires de: [voix plus aigu] Ah tu vois il est tout petit
C'est à cause de mec comme toi que je souffre
A: Ben, ben descend du banc déjà, ça ira mieux
*rires*
A: Coucou les abonnés. Ah ils... peuvent réagir, ils peuvent dire des choses?
F: Ouais ouais
A: Ah c'est génial
Et les coups de Boost de l'humour ça se passe au théâtre du Trévise
Le magnifique théâtre du Trévise
Je monte sur scène pour vous faire voir
Là évidemment le public n'est pas encore rentré
sinon on pourrait dire qu'on allait passer une bonne soirée
- Est ce que tu veux bien qu'on essaie la guitare stp?
Alex: Ouais
- Sans vouloir te commander
- Alors par contre j'ai horreur qu'on me filme
F: C'est quand même ce que tu fais
*rires*
F: Quoi. Attends on a pas bien entendu
- Moi j'ai horreur qu'on me filme. En plus, on m'a même pas demandé mon avis. Vous vous rendez compte.
F: Pour une meuf, qui aime pas qu'on la filme, elle se colle bien près de la caméra quand même
C'est tout ce que j'ai à dire *rires*
- C'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
F: Là on est à 10min du spectacle et en loge je ne trouvais pas l'équipe d'organisation
Où est ce qui peuvent être juste avant le spectacle?
- C'est un rasoir, un rasoir électrique *rires*
*imitation du rasoir électrique*
- Tu as vu je suis rasé de près
- Faudrait faire une vidéo, euh une photo de Gaëtan Mathis sous le
*rire*
G: Je préfère mourir libre
- Faire une vidéo enfin une photo avec Gaëtan on va se mettre...
alors que tu vois les gens regarde, ils s'arrêtent pas
Jésus reviens, jésus reviens
- Non mais euh...
- C'est un rasoir
-C'est un rasoir *rire* non mais c'est quoi?
F: Une caméra
- C'est marrant ce format
F: Ouais
- GoPro machin, j'aime bien. Ah et ça s'accroche sur ...
- Canon oui c'est canon
- C'est avec ça que tu te filmes, Non?
- C'est vachement bien
-  Tu fais signer des trucs à la fin. Genre Oui j'accepte d’apparaître dans la vidéo de Fabien Olicard
F: Ouais ouais
- J'ai pas signé.
F: Je te met le bon ici
Je te met ton bon de droit à l'image ici
- Fabien Olicard filme avec Canon
D'accord?
Super matos Canon
et d'ailleurs si, il m'écoute je veux bien un échantillon
*rires*
Parce que j'aime beaucoup
- Je veux bien un échantillon 7, 5, 7D
J: Ange et Dumont
Ange et Dumont
- Ah oui c'est bien
F: Regardez, quand tu vois un mec faire ça avec une chaise tu te dis: Forcément il y a un truc qui va pas
Personne ne comprend où tu veux t'asseoir là Didier
*rires*
F: Tu sais dans les loges du Trévise tu retrouves quand même des vieilles affiches
- Celle du Cosson en haut
F: Oh la vache
- Arnaud. Il a quoi? il est pas majeur
- Gidouin. Ah attend il est où?
- y'a Alévêque aussi
F: Je crois que les gens commence à rentrer
Allons voir
*Bruit des spectateurs*
F: Vous voulez savoir un truc drôle?
Je sais pas encore ce que je vais faire sur scène
j'ai pas encore décidé
Faut pas le dire à Didier et à Edouard
il me reprogrammeront pas sinon *rire*
- Bidou
*rires*
- Ah non
F: A la réalisation, Didier Foret.
Au effet spéciaux Alex & sa guitare
*rire*
F: Regarde on peut faire: Couillou. Il a mal rangé
*rires*
David Bosteli: *Chante*
- Monsieur Bosteli si vous êtes prêt, on peut lancer la soirée
D: Allez c'est parti
F: On ne m'a jamais appelé Monsieur Fabien
- Pour mardi prochain c'est bon?
- Mardi prochain, allez mardi prochain on fait une soirée .
- En huit
- A priori en huit
- sur les coups de 16h
F: Vous voulez connaître le secret de Bosteli contre le trac?
D: Heineken
Al: C'est la 4ème
F: La 4ème?
Al: Je m'amuse à compter
F: Et à balancer surtout
Al: Rohhh
F: Ça c'est ton petit côté aréhin
Al: Non mais c'est important d'aider les collègues
F: Ah 2ème Arehin
F: Franchement si c'est encore pour se moquer de Didier Foret
*rires* Je trouve ça inadmissible
- Pas du tout
F: Tout ça pour se moquer de Didier mais sans déconner
F: Je ne sais plus qui est notre directeur artistique de ce soir
Al: [Blasé] Si faut mettre une perruque pour avoir du talent
ça se saurait
- Chut. C'est parti
*Applaudissement du public*
F: Quelques choses me dit que c'est parti
D: En tout cas, bienvenue les amis, bienvenue à tous aux coups de boost de l'humour
faut savoir que cette soirée on l'a débuté pour la 1ère fois. C'était au festival d'Avignon
il y a des gens dans la salle qui connaissent le festival d'Avignon?
Oui. Tu as déjà été au festival d'Avignon.
Toi aussi tu est déjà allé au festival d'avignon?
C'est super
et bien au festival d'Avignon il y a énormément de spectacle, énormément de pression et on s'est dit pourquoi pas faire un plateau entre copain
pour décompresser; voilà
F: Moi je peux faire le 1er plan et toi tu gagnes de la richesse du coup
*rires*
- Tu parles de la situation. Je la joue
- Je te fais
F: La colère
- Ça dépend tu veux le côté cinématographique ou théâtrale?
F: Penses aux recettes de ta billeterie
*rires*
F: Non ça c'est le dégoût, la déception, l'humiliation.
Non non la colère
- D'accord
F: Là c'est bon la colère c'est bon
- Non là on est plus sur le... *fait un regard coléreux"
*rire*
F: C'est vrai que... là je me suis dit faut que je me méfie de ce mec.
Ainsi s'achève les coups de boost de l'humour. Merci Didier
D: Merci Fabien.
F: Tu étais content de ta soirée?
D: Ah grave
grave, public hyper réactif et tout ils étaient au taquet. Et je suis surtout content de vos passages à tous respectivement
qui était vraiment efficace
F: Sauf d'un mais on dira pas qui parce qu'on veut pas lui faire mal au cœur à JeanFi
D: Ben non on le dira pas à JeanFi
G: Ah oui c'était dur. Va peut être falloir dire à Jean-Fi que c'est bien steward *rires*
F: Toi quand ils viennent te voir soit ils rient, soit ils vomissent mais ils se passent quelques choses
G: Il y a 2 personnes qui sont sorties?
D: Oui 2 personnes qui sont sorties
F: Elles sont parties sur le passage de Gaëtan Mathis
G: Je sais pas sur quelle vanne?!
F: Je trouve que ça c'est ta meilleure promo en fait
G: Ouais
F: De dire venez me voir, par exemple, cesoir il y a 2 personnes qui ont pas supporté
G: Il y a rien que je trouve plus jubilatoire que de faire rire les gens que de faire hurler les cons
et ça je trouve que c'est un vrai plaisir de...
D: Ah ben ce soir ça a bien marché hein!
*rires*
- Elles sont parties au moment du porno
G: C'est vrai
- Ça a été la blague de trop pour elles. Elles ont pris leurs manteaux et elles sont parties en mode "Oh non c'est trooop"
G: C'est celle dont je suis le plus fier en plus
- Et je trouve ça très drôle mais...
G: Oh ben merci
-... je crois qu'elles ont pas aimé le porno et compagnie. Tu as demandé à un mec: Tu te branles sur quoi toi? Il a fait Oh non mais non et il est sorti
G: oh merde
D: oui c'est ça
F: Non mais le vrai soucis ce qu'on précise pas c'est que c'est un spectacle pour enfants
G: Oui *rires*
F: Alors évidemment dans cette proportion là vous comprenez plus
F: *Chante* Badabadadam
Ta ta ta ta ta ta
-Les vieux, les vieux arrivent sur YouTube
F: ta ta ta ta ta
- Nouveau trentenaire sur YouTube
F: Thug life [prononciation française]
ta ta ta
- Tu gliffe?
F: Thug life [prononciation anglaise]
F: Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo. Si ça vous a plu de nous voir dans notre environnement naturel *rire*, évoluer tel un petit reportage animalier
Vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un
Pouce en l'air
N'oubliez pas, également, de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir.
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez vous demain à 17h
Ciao!